support the david pakman show and pick
yourself up a Janus SmartWatch designed
by Chronos blade I love mine it can do
anything my phone can do you can take
photos with the dual camera a
videoconference download any Android app
use it as a fitness tool it can make
calls like a phone it has GPS it has one
of the biggest screens out there 1.6
inches
check it out using the link right
underneath this video I told you on
Monday that 105 House Democrats now
publicly support an impeachment inquiry
against Donald Trump that number has
increased and the House Democrats have
now reached and surpassed the 50% mark
to get to an impeachment inquiry the
house has 435 members half plus 1 is 218
the number of Democrats now supporting
an impeachment inquiry is at least 109
exactly half of that 218 and according
to some reports it's as high as 117
including the support of former
Republican congressman Justin Amash who
we have talked about is abandoning the
Republican Party for very good reasons
that indicate is concerned with what's
going on there so remember Republicans
are not needed to reach 50% plus one
support because Democrats took control
of the house in the 2018 midterms
another one of the ways in which that
election was extremely important and
every election is important now there
are a few things that are continuing to
hold this number back why is there not
more support for an impeachment inquiry
in the House of Representatives number
one if Nancy Pelosi the Democratic
Speaker of the House said yeah it's time
it's time to start the impeachment
inquiry that would instantly increase
support among Democrats in the House of
Representatives secondly there are
Democrats in red states who are worried
about the consequences in their 2020
re-election campaigns if they support an
impeachment inquiry that their
constituents don't like I do not think
that this is a real issue the power of
incumbency is going to be outdone by
simply standing up for what you believe
in or let me kind of frame it a
different way if a Republican can knock
out an income
Democrat simply by saying the Democrat
is bad because they wanted an
impeachment inquiry that's not a
Democrat who has a very strong hold of
their district to begin with so I don't
buy that nonsense for even a second and
then there's one other important thing
to remember which is that half of House
Democrats or a little more now publicly
support an impeachment inquiry of course
there are more who support it privately
but for different reasons have not yet
decided to go public could be for the
reasons I mentioned before could be for
reasons I haven't mentioned the number
109 is noteworthy or 117 or whatever the
number is it's noteworthy both for how
large it is and for how small it is what
I mean by that is on the one hand it's
not common for half of the members of
one party in Congress to want to start
an impeachment inquiry against the
president when Barack Obama was
president you didn't have half of House
Republicans wanting an impeachment
inquiry against them because it wouldn't
have made any sense with george w bush
you didn't have half of democrats
wanting to start an impeachment inquiry
against george w bush and he did some
really really bad things so this is a
very large number in the sense that it's
trouble for donald trump but there's
another side to that how is it that only
109 or 117 members of congress are
publicly foreign impeachment inquiry
given everything that we have already
learned all that needs to happen is
Nancy Pelosi saying I believe we need to
start an impeachment inquiry if she does
that it's over it's already unusual to
see 109 or 117 break with the public
view of the Speaker of the House from
their own party if Pelosi comes around
we will have an impeachment inquiry in
the end she should come around because
it's the right thing to do and it's her
job the only good argument I have heard
for not starting an impeachment inquiry
today is the idea that starting and in
six months might be more damaging to
Donald Trump and I would be okay with
that short of that explanation I don't
see any reason not to start an
impeachment inquiry immediately and I
want to hear from you about it make sure
that you're following
david pakman show on instagram at david
pakman show and while you're there
throw me a follow as well at david
pakman